une fébrilité inhabituelle règne au
centre d'hébergement de la prairie
quatre mariées se prépare à renouveler
leur et comme le veut la tradition
tout se fait loin du regard des efforts
des employés du ch et celle des ont tout
mis en oeuvre pour que ce soit un grand
grand jour nous ont tellement aidé
l'équipe entière
ces groupes vraiment des moments là
quand le 6 de la montérégie ouest a
proposé de faire de mai le mois du
bonheur deux employés ont pensé à re
marier les couples que la maladie assez
paris ce que on voit qu'ils sont
vraiment présente et qui viennent tous
les auvents leur mari ou leur femme
énormément au début mais y embarquer
dans le flou
ce conte ans après 60 ans de mariage
raymond daigneault est arrivé au centre
d'hébergement ou janvier qui moquent à
la maison suis un vieux d'énormément
mais par conséquent la gêne voire le
pilote possible je m'emporte ces petites
barres de chocolat jamais kindia cunene
plus depuis at il indiqué
on a sollicité tout le monde qu'on
pouvait sur facebook c'est pas grave nos
contacts et tout le monde essayait
vraiment embarqué dans le projet
facilement je dirais que les gens un
grand quart des dons ont permis de
décorer d'habiller les mariés et de
créer une cérémonie inoubliable
on
si la maladie d'alzheimer a mis un voile
sur les souvenirs de raymond daigneault
il n'a rien oublié du jour où il a
rencontré sa femme ou mariage d'un
cousin une belle femme plus jeune j'ai
vu tu seras plus jamais bien des
hommages aux cheveux noirs et blancs
mais je dirais qu'avec des beaux yeux
bleus les cheveux s'alliant comme gage
devant le minimum est ce voulu
mais l'humeur des souvenirs en viadène
qui les ont poussés à dire encore une
fois mis ici anne louise des tati
radio-canada à la prairie